Michael what would you advise someone
that has a loving family but maybe
they're worried for their child you know
brother sister whatever how would an
actor a creative person explained to
them I realized that there's going to be
bumps in the road and it may not be easy
and I may be chasing this dream for
years and it may never happen but I
still want to do it that's that is a
good question it's I'm trying to
formulate an answer because I have not
been in those shoes but I can imagine
that and I mean there's there's the old
cliché of lid it's true though if you
can find anything else that would make
you just as happy in your life do that
because it's probably going to be easier
you know it's probably going to be a
more stable road whatever it is because
this is one of the most unstable things
you can choose to do with your life but
there's also that part of you that you
have to do it you know this is that you
this is what I've been wanting to do in
chasing since fifth grade and then it's
just it's always what's driven me it's
always what's gotten me out of bed and
excite you know the most excited I've
been is because of this so if you truly
have that passion and no this is what
you want to do just heartfelt pics you
know in a heartfelt way express that to
them and if they don't fully support you
you you have to just keep going and know
that you'll have to find that support
elsewhere you know like I mean I'm not
saying I this is a hard question for me
to answer because it's not my experience
you know I mean the I know I've had a
lot of friends who have wanted to go to
college for it and their parents are
paying for their college and won't let
them major in acting and to those people
I say go to college and get whatever
degree your parents will pay for and
then start auditioning you know you
don't need that college degree
training helped short is do would i
recommend training yes but if you don't
have the support to because i know
college is expensive and all that and if
you don't have the support to go to
college for acting and you need to get
your degree in something else that
doesn't mean you you know then you can
pursue it after there's there's plenty
of roads
you